all right last question from tim what is
this this involves a note they gave me
a note on white privilege okay this was
posted on facebook by a former
homeschooler
whose child was just just started at st
paul's catholic high school in bristol
connecticut
overall it's a decent school however
this handout was given out in a
school-wide assembly yesterday
i'm curious to hear your thoughts on
work politics infiltrating even private
catholic schools
this is on white privilege oh there's a
number of bullet points or 26 bullet
points i'll just go through a few
so i guess it's it's explaining what
white privilege is i can if i wish
arranged to be in the company of people
of my race most of the time
i think i think a lot of people can do
that you can see you see
self-segregation in neighborhoods and
social circles so everybody can do that
if they wish
i can be sure that my neighbors in a
location that i move to will be neutral
or pleasant to me
i can't assure that and not just because
i'm a little swarthy or something
i i think that i mean there are blm
signs in every yard in every
city or suburb in all of america so i
think it's not a racial issue
but i can't assure that when i move into
a neighborhood people will be pleasant
to me the minute they find out my
politics they hate my guts
because if you're a conservative in
america today you are
counter-cultural you're you are you have
a politics of dissent
from what we've been talking about all
show this liberal establishment so
so that actually that backs up my thesis
right that's my
that the real privilege is kind of
liberal elite privilege not
a racial question i can turn on the
television or open the front page of a
newspaper and see people of my race
widely represented
there's a ton of entertainment for black
people and hispanic people in this right
you've got tv stations you've got
magazines you've got outlets you've got
websites that's crazy if i want to i can
be pretty sure finding a publisher for
this piece on white privilege
well you can because it's liberal but
it's not because of your race
first of all getting books published is
hard but you could get this dribble
published anywhere couldn't you
right it is it's published in every
liberal outlet on the internet
okay blah blah blah posters cards oh
here we go oh here's one this actually
ties right in
to the top of the show number 22 i can
take a job with an affirmative action
employer
without having co-workers on the job
suspect that i got it because of my race
that's the privilege so even affirmative
action is actually
a way to disadvantage white and asian
people
by law and they make all these arguments
for it so but that is it right it's to
racially discriminate against white
nation people and even that now is taken
as a
symptom of white privilege because if
you do get a job and you're whiter asian
you can at least be said to think that
you got what you deserve except
the whole ideology of white privilege
says that nothing you have is something
that you deserve
total incoherent drivel it's very sad
that a catholic school would do that
catholic schools are supposed to be more
conservative than the insanity at the
public schools but the rot runs very
deep
runs very very deep it's not just nancy
pelosi and hillary clinton it's not just
a couple elected politicians
it runs all the way down through the
media through hollywood through
technology through the schools
through the catholic schools through the
catholic church through
and when i say the catholic church i
just mean that as an example of the most
conservative institution
it goes throughout all of the protestant
denominations
all over the west that is a deeply
embedded privilege how do we
reform that system of oppression i hope
you enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]